[Music]
we're dramatically disadvantaged as a
country because of the impact of traffic
the average nigerian burst hours every
day in traffic we just don't have the
infrastructure to support the amount of
people in this city
[Music]
here in lagos nigeria traffic can get
well
pretty bad
so two friends had enough of waiting
around
they had a plan
i'm additional by maduro and now i'm
trinido azudo and we are co-founders of
maxstar energy
max is a mobile app that provides
africans access to motorcycle taxis in
real time
and what we do is we train drivers
regulate them
and then connect them to customers we
need to move from one point to the other
we also connect those drivers to
individuals and businesses who have
packages they want to deliver
from point a to point b
[Music]
and addition met while studying in the
states they took a few classes together
and both realized they wanted to help
their home country while we were there
we both had the passion to transform and
to change africa and we asked ourselves
you know what is the best way for us to
create a lot of jobs and what kind of
problem that can we solve that would
make a lot of impact
you see nigeria is one of the fastest
growing countries or population
standpoint with the infrastructure that
we have available today motorcycles
solve the problem you see everything
else gets stuck in traffic a car gets
stuck in traffic
bosses get stuck in traffic the
motorcycles allow their drivers to dart
in and out of traffic easily thus saving
time and being able to make more
deliveries
so far the company has hired over 500
people and change the lives of many
nigerian families
china do and taiyo see it as their
mission to make a change in lagos and
the rest of africa according to max
their drivers make two and a half the
industry average
a wage that can set them on a path to
financial success
what we can do to make life better for
everybody we do that to the best of our
abilities
[Music]